Buon Giorno my name is Henry Goulding
and I am going undercover on the
intranet this is actually me Twitter can
I swear in this Natalie you got potty
mouth so who the [ __ ] on here makes
movies
what is Henry Gordon going to be in next
I'm obsessed with him and can't wait
Spain $19 to see him for two straight
hours and again
well crazier Jason's done simple favor
done I have an independent girl monsoon
which we're figuring out which festival
to go into I am starting production last
Christmas with Paul Feig Emilia Clarke
and Emma Thompson and I've also got a
very secret top secret amazing
production with Guy Ritchie John
extremely excited about because I grew
up with Guy Ritchie loves talking to
Smoking Barrels snatch the guy's a
legend cannot wait how has had regarding
only four acting credits on IMDB
technically there's only three or three
of them maybe for now but there's a
whole list of like they always list what
choice you've been on as well so that
kind of beefed up my IMDB but by the end
of the year I'm hoping there are going
to be six so what's-his-face
Henry garlic did you realize that a TV
you hood up all your travel shows
especially without boundaries about a
month ago
what a throwback to days when I used to
watch you on quickie and a TV back in KL
so damn proud of you and crazy rotations
Henry Malaysian pride my first ever ever
ever show on television was called the
quickie was a 15-minute live TV show
every single day and then I continued
with travel shows but without boundaries
beaches and Islands there is welcome to
the real world Sabah earthquake their
uncle is no more
you know what just search on youtube you
find them Instagram
you look sad man you all right yeah I
mean I think I was half-expecting that
it's a very melodramatic photo but no
I'm on top of the world right now work
is fantastic loving this new Hollywood
thing but it's a lot of hard work I
think this was a combination of
promoting two movies back to back and
ending up on the couch this is what I
look like on a day-to-day basis watching
Netflix on the couch in my undies
slouching it's good vision G YouTube and
addiction which I need to see somebody
about I think what I got in the in the
the end-of-year book was sexual healer
did he go to a posh boarding school
where did he get that accent I grew up
in a state school which is your everyday
school in the suburbs of the UK no
possible at all not private school I
think I just picked it up as I went
along and it kind of turns a little
transatlantic my wife is what she has
just like international accent so
sometimes I just do funny things with my
arse and yeah but I still pronounce
water water instead of water like over
here replied if he has never acted
before how come I see comments that most
Malaysians have watched him before that
is because when I was a hair stylist in
London I moved back to Asia 2008 when I
was 21 under the premise and under the
guise of trying to get on television
because I love the idea of being a host
it looked really fun manage that and
have been doing that for eight years now
so I've been around I'm an old hag
really horrid does Henry Goulding speak
Chinese was his Chinese pronunciation on
crazy rich Asians Acura I can't lie
about this I did most of the Chinese in
the ADR room which means we Frankenstein
a lot of my really terrible Chinese
sounds because I'm pretty much
death and Chinese you gotta use tones so
no submit what are some cultural
references in greater iterations that a
non-asian audience might miss cuckoo
Chao it's been attires pretty much catch
line or something that he shouts out a
lot it is from Malaysia / Singapore it
means submit
I am DB his mother is from the ebon
people an indigenous group in Sarawak
and Henry completed the by July and ebon
rite of passage in the jungles of Borneo
absolutely truth cuz I went on this
amazing production with Discovery
Channel undergoing this but July is like
a journey into manhood ended up with a
humongous tattoo on my right thigh which
I still have to this day Wikipedia the
tattoo on his right thigh is a fig tree
that wraps around other trees and takes
their phone to become the tree itself
true and it also has heads of dragons on
either side it's abstract it's not
really a dragon much like Ben Affleck's
Phoenix on his back no it's formed into
the shape of so dragon heads to
represent sort of becoming oneself and
you were meant to be posting more
Twitter sounds really stupidly honest
more Twitter more Twitter more Twitter
even more Twitter you know how some even
men and women sometimes mulatto in ebon
do you think Henry Goulding mulatto in
the ebon when he gets scared I thought
you know mulatto just explained is
almost it's it's like a slight
Tourette's in terms of when you get
scared or somebody scares you you shout
out the first thing that's in your head
which is often a swear word or something
extremely obscene so no I don't Henry
Golding how does the night diving feel
as compared to today diving what's the
difference you don't see [ __ ] at night
that's just be honest then you have a
torchlight and if the the visible
these crap you can't see anything I did
a dive show where I went round the
beaches and Islands of Malaysia
fantastic places Sipadan marble capital
a lion lion more some of the most
beautiful dive sites I went diving at
night once never again wasn't very good
Happy's thinks Henry Golding should be
the next Superman do you agree or who
else would you suggest I know half is
he's from fly FM in Malaysia good friend
and hell's yeah why not
Asian Superman sure I have that many
muscles though I think I'd have to hit
the gym after fair or now Henry Cavill
is a hunky man all right that's all we
have every golding sign enough